President Bush's political life was part
of a robust family legacy his father
Prescott Bush was a u.s. senator from
Connecticut mr. Bush and his son
president george w bush are the only or
only the second I should say a
father-son duo to occupy the Oval Office
the other of course is John Adams and
John Quincy Adams Jen Crawford is in
Houston with the past and future of the
bush political dynasty Jan good morning
well good morning so the legacy of
George HW Bush is going to be debated by
historians for years to come but when
you start to look at the professional
and the personal a common theme emerges
and that's a commitment to service the
country was together and everyone wanted
to do one's duty I just had that driving
feeling that I ought to ought to go into
the service in both his military career
and in political life George Herbert
Walker Bush was driven by a sense of
duty he's often said that any definition
of a successful life must include
service to others and that just defines
most of his life Tim McBride served as
mr. Bush's personal aide are you
carrying the bags here yep that's right
that was my job I saw the president as a
father figure
McBride was with Bush on Inauguration
Day in 1989 minutes before he was to be
sworn in as president mr. Bush made a
curious observation president-elect Bush
notices that mrs. Reagan is bundling up
very snugly President Reagan he's gonna
wear he's gonna wear a coat she's
wrapping a scarf around and he is
clearly ready for much colder conditions
so the president-elect demanded his own
coat nice sir your coach down in the car
we won't get it in time it's not
possible he's why I need it I can't go
out looking more robust than President
Reagan but what I have proposed despite
his empathy mr. Bush lost his
re-election bid in 1992 by 2001 another
Bush George W was back in the Oval
Office as I recall the conversation went
something like this welcome mr.
president it's good to see you mr.
president
and that's always said they'll remember
him from being a good finest president
who may got a lot of things done but
thanks I think the thing I take pride in
is
integrity how does he was according to
McBride mr. Bush did not set out to
build a political dynasty none of that
motivated him or I believe motivates any
of his family a sentiment Jeb Bush the
former Florida governor echoed when he
ran for president in 2016 the idea of
being a bush I know it's complicated for
people looking out on the outside I can
distinguish between being proud to be a
member of this extraordinary family and
also recognizing I got to go make this
case myself
amid declarations that he was doomed by
his last name Jeb Bush dropped out of
the GOP primary I once heard someone
just say that the times choose the
president you think his last name was
Smith he would have had a better chance
I think running as a bush would have
been tough and 16 for any candidate but
beyond that there were other factors
that caused the voters to look somewhere
else I think voters may one day look
toward yet another bush Jeb's son George
Prescott hi George Prescott Bush
currently the Texas Land Commissioner
George P Bush seemed destined to join
the family business I pledge allegiance
to the flag at 12 years old he led the
Pledge of Allegiance at the Republican
National Convention that nominated his
grandfather now the fourth generation of
his family to enter politics George P
did so with his uncle's blessings he's
always thought that I'd be good at it
but in terms of doing it for the right
reasons that's what the consensus was
whether it was him or my grandfather and
my dad is you've got to do this with a
servant's heart with the unwavering
heart of a servant mr. Bush leaves
behind a legacy that transcends politics
you can't believe what our grandchildren
do they all do something for others they
do public service they do something for
others
now George P Bush is one of the most
popular politicians in Texas where here
the bush name still resonates and even
if he doesn't decide to run for
president
there are 16 grandchildren and eight
grandchildren who pit some day in her
public office Nora
Wow we can count them all Jan thank you
so much